here
yeah how's it
going I got some work to do
today I've been taking a bit of time bit
more than normal in the mornings just to
uh you know go through and post some
stuff here
it's been really helping for uh getting
people interested in puffer and getting
new contributors on
boarded almost
5600 Discord as well is about to hit
700 that's pretty
today what we're going to do
today I think I'm all caught up on this
stuff um we're going to update a few
small
things on this announcements
Tab and then I think we're going to do
some core Dev on puff for today there're
just a few last little things that are
bothering people with uh the advanced
API
and uh we're going to fix those and then
we'll see what else we get done
today but that's going to be the
main um
shoot and what happened with our
of
okay first thing to update
here I think somebody just checked
out long
right I saw somebody check out pong I
need to get their
[Music]
username track
okay here's the
guy skip streamer mode
weird
[Music]
okay I think the only other
moment welcome YouTube folks think we'll
start on the dev
now okay we're going to do uh I think
local for the first part
today uh I was messing with this Connect
4 M but we'll put that on hold for
now so the main thing I was going to
look at and this is actually kind of
cool if you're interested in like lower
level as well as bindings across
ocean
oops so what I was wondering
here and I got this idea from one of the
collaborators is whether I can replace
these with memory
views and if I replace these with memory
views these CNP andd arrays I think the
data is the same but I should get better
type checks and um one of the worst bugs
we have at the moment is it's very easy
to shoot yourself in the foot by passing
data buffers of the wrong type which
then get they basically like will Heap
overflow stuff um
okay so like right now let's I think
what we're going to do today is we're
going to do this on breakout we're going
to see if it works and if it does work
we'll just add it on to all the M's I'll
try to do that very quickly and uh yeah
we'll see from
what's the action
here int actions unsigned int
actions okay so here's a a different
data type right unsigned in
error maybe we get runtime though let's
see
ah look at
that buffer mismatch expected int got
float that's what we want
let's see if it can pick up this in the
unsigned in thing
I'm not typing
constantly not
typing this is actually kind of nice cuz
you get Dimension
checks yeah this is really the killer
feature of syon I don't know why I
stopped using it I think I forgot that
you could use it in this
way
ument I
lots of good
contributors did I tag ARB on the
uh I tagged ARB
already very
solid I probably should clean this up a
bit at some
point I kind of like just leaving it as
a
Discord comment
though I think once you start to get
like stupid Trello boards and like
Discord board or like GitHub boards and
stuff it's just it's too much dumb
this already Discord carb scale options
yeah
so if you want to mess with
it you can just like assume
that the scale is going to be the
standard deviation with which it
searches
um so like a reasonable thing with
updates is probably one and then with
like total time steps I don't know maybe
it's like 10% of the total time steps or
something you can try that I will say
that like carbs is very janky and we've
had lots and lots of bugs and errors
with it but uh even when it's bugged
it still typically has been like way
better than basy in a random search so
if you want to spin up extra experiments
on like random or something you can do
that but carbs has been pretty good for
us we definitely need to figure out
carbs a little bit better um David uh
bluman in the uh the
Discord has like a a repo where he's
been working on that um but pretty much
carbs is just like a very intricate
algorithm seems to work very well but
like the released implementation it's
missing a bunch of guard checks there
are a lot of ways to shoot yourself in
the feet and um I mean still been good
despite all of
that 10% of Max Pam space depending on
the parameter so
like there's also a space type right so
I don't know if you notice like we have
like logic spaces or whatever for um
parameters that are 0er to one range and
then there's like uniform spaces and
whatnot um there's also like the X
spased
stuff so you can try like 10% for run
length I don't think it's I really don't
think that that's going to make the huge
difference though like it that's
potentially a longer project to really
figure out what the heck carbs is
doing if you're interested in doing that
there's actually a huge amount of value
in
like really good stable hyper pram
tuning
stuff um but probably outside the scope
of what you're trying to do
this has got to be supported by now
right
this is such a good
feature does this actually just let you
do
right
yeah
I think it's an unsigned Char anyways
isn't
it I doubt anyone knows right this is
like random stuff
8 so I think we can just do unsign
Char unsign Char
cannot
convert to numpy
so has
a view scon
to see as
[Music]
this
fair pass.
data all right so this says you can just
pass.
we shouldn't need a cast either
right we shouldn't need a
indentation what did I
forget ah
when I mess
up this is some dumb syntax thing
this
terminal
duns can not assign
type
okay if this works it's going to
basically make this simpler and
Bulletproof
huh so this is float
star let's see if this
works okay so this actually seems to
work it is
assign type
inar to unsign charar
so just mute desktop audio I don't know
if those notifications are going
what does actions have to be unsigned
charar
something cannot
assign type in Star to unsign char
star doesn't look like an unsign
Char right
odd is it like
um
no is it an unsigned in is this the
problem
it's pretty bizarre def find wrong up
here ah it is defined wrong up
here these really should be autogen so
we don't have this Arrow
see nefarious this stuff
is so easy to mess it
up and now we get unsigned int which is
much much
better there's really no reason to have
it be unsigned in though
really no reason at
all to not just have it be an
we're going to figure out this syntax
eventually and then it's going to be
very easy for
everyone um
I mean you can see why this type of
setup work though is important and not
necessarily trivial for people because
there's a whole bunch of type
Shenanigans going on in the background
I don't know why it wouldn't be that
easy hold
on if you can actually do this this is
amazing syntax
we got to make sure that this is correct
before we ship
it would be very nice if we had this m
training correctly
swear what is wrong with my breakout
implementation
here just doesn't like to
incompatible M view
size it's very weird
data
H not contiguous
it's so weird that you can't just pass
this right
this would be very nice if it worked but
I can't tell
data
um interesting
sh okay so these are the data is correct
here this is really gross
though if if that warning were
strict it would be
so if we just make that pointer thing
cuz that pointer warning is very bad
usually so and I know I have it in a few
places in the library as
well so if we're just strict with
now that's going to be a bit pedantic
I'm sure but we can do this for now
actually wait can't this just
be I think I don't want these to have to
be in every file
of is this inside this is not inside of
scyon is it oh yeah yeah yeah this is I
just have really dumb
um yeah I just have really dumb uh
indentation here this is inside of scyon
eyes okay
there's got to be a compilation thing
for this right
Shenanigans looks like it's a legitimate
just screw up with numpy
yeah this should just go into setup.py
somehow
yeah I don't know what you're saying if
you're just trolling then you can go
elsewhere we're doing uh we're trying to
get some cool RL stuff done
here it's not
always the day today is not always going
to be something super sexy but this type
of stuff will make it much much much
easier for people in this space
mean I should just be able to do this
right this just defines an arbitrary
macro so like
right
yeah there we
go look at that
this is pretty good we got the compile
um we assume this now compiles with no
warnings if I do if I forget right if I
do like this
compilation
fails what are you doing I'm fixing the
I'm making some improvements
to the uh the puffer API at the moment
not really API more like the way that we
do
stuff um just to make it easier for
people to bind RL
environments from python to cython or
C this is the new way that we have it
here where I'm using memory
views and I'm getting addresses of
memory views like this versus
before if we look at like here's an M
that I haven't done it yet for we can
see you just get generic numpy arrays
here and you got to do some extra
Shenanigans and casting here and uh you
also don't get type checks on this and
it's actually it's very very easy to
pass like bad buffers and Heap overflow
in shenanigans
now I have it set up
[Music]
so there's basically no way to screw it
up and it's
simpler so that's an
improvement does this actually train
now might have to get some better
compile flags for scon as well but
okay which programming language the
stack is um scon on top of c and then
python on top of scon I guess we're
mainly we have it's it's mostly Python
and C um with scon as an
intermediary those SQL a little
bit sqls more of a domain specific
language
still I we'll give this a couple minutes
to see if it uh produces
anything now I'll have to debug it
promising okay so hyp bad hyper
parameters or whatever it takes a little
while to get started but then it looks
like it starts to actually learn the
game score is going up
since when do you
program
uh I mean it depends how
seriously at
least least 11 years maybe closer to
like 15
all
right looks like it
this hopefully we don't break everything
by doing this with the other M's but um
this is a
pretty stantial advancment is it your
job of
course I am am
uh working full-time
on making reinforcement
learning a sane and usable field
what's up training policies for the MS
no I uh I just fixed one of the biggest
possible sources of errors with the
bindings welcome
Spencer you see the new format here num
ND CNP ND replaced with M views like
this and just
address actually don't even need CNP
import anymore
right yeah we don't even need CNP
import oh we don't need the OS import
either we just need the calic and
free look at
that that's a big Improvement
Improvement I'm quite pleased with that
uh I guess I'm going to just go through
all the m and apply
this should be a non-breaking change
test
you
uh anything for me to check on go
Spencer
n away was huge
reason yeah this well it is the same
thing though it's literally the same so
this is the same data under the hood
it's still mirroring into the ND arrays
this is just it's a different
syntax um it's scon defines this thing
called a memory view which is basically
the same but you get type checking in
better syntax
so there will be no performance
difference whatsoever from doing
you're still using numpy Rays you pass a
numpy ray and then but it interprets it
as a m it's kind of
cool I have a branch if pushed up with
some clean up on go
waiting till a box is off I just
messaged I I messaged the guy on that
let me see if you
replied uh received but no
response on
um you can do a quick run on my box zero
which is just J Suarez that puffer box
if you need to I think that one is still
up I think the job I have on that is
done by
now and it's not really important
anyways let me see me go double check
for
you stupid power outages
man I'm going back to Florida in a week
so I'll be able to go fix some boxes
box shouldn't have either way whatever
you want to do what the heck oh that's
just a g that's whatever okay
look at this so you replace the ND array
with those like
simpler types you just delete this you
get to delete this as well isn't that
nice and then you literally just do
and like
simpler we will be getting more uh we'll
definitely be getting that cluster back
in working order so we'll have all the
boxes up properly once I get there and
I'm like able to fix stuff so that'll
take a little bit of pressure off I'll
actually be there in person to uh reboot
them whenever is needed at least for a
good few months which will be nice a
couple months which will be nice and uh
yeah we'll see after
that I want to get more of the machines
though as well
isn't this nice look this is a uh a
warning that previously would have
broken your thing silently and now we
actually get to see look we don't want
to break it
silently we get the exact error message
which is the pointer incompatibility
we just change
actions from an unsigned int to an INT
because there's no reason for it to be
an unsigned
int literally just more characters to
be nice if we were getting logs I don't
know where our logs
are oh there they
are just takes a long time to finish the
games I
guess next steps work on training good
policies carbs then mess around with
stuff or other way around uh you want to
get so what you do is you get a policy
that kind of like kind of trains
something reasonable but you don't
obsess over like how good it is and then
you let carbs actually find good
parameters for
you actually if you're interested in the
RL side of things and you want to kind
of do a little bit of experiment work I
would be uh I'd be very happy to let you
do the to have you do the
baselines for a lot of the simpler Ms
that would save me some time
because you know I've got core stuff to
do on on puffer as well as the the
harder like more complex M's for the
release you could probably get a decent
baselines for you know for go Connect
Four triple Triad pong break out like
all these all these
Ms wouldn't be that
hard I mean you can literally run tens
of billions of steps of train runs per
day on one GPU with this as long as the
box is up for
you yeah so I will show you exactly what
uh what you do with this
so let me explain so first of all not
all the M's are guaranteed to be
perfectly correct so if nothing is
training at all then you know there's a
possibility something is broken with the
data so what you do for that is like you
know you go put a break point like right
here and I see solve
observations okay
step you can see that they changed are
they they all the same no we've got some
variability okay good and you start sort
of looking from there you do the same
thing with like rewards actions make
sure all the buffers are are linked
up and then what you would do is you go
into
config you set some reasonable settings
in order to like try to make sure that
you have reasonable convergence um these
are very
aggressive look at like how many mini
batches there going to be for every
batch so I would probably
do I'll probably just like we're
probably going to just go up to this by
default unless proven
otherwise uh this thing doesn't need to
be changed probably we don't need
this this we can probably just do like
that j e Lambda this is crazy
low and 9 five I guess but really this
needs to be
higher
seven one yeah so we just set some
reasonable starting points which I can
give you where you can help you can
decide on I mean I can tell you how I
make all the decisions I just made there
they're not like genius decisions or
anything it's also not really nice how
long this thing takes to log might want
to do something about
that but okay so here we have episode
return is
increasing I think episode return is
number of hits or something and then
score is number of points it's really
really weird that it takes this long to
train um because you can train like
classic pong and just a few million
steps completely without even having
this reward so this definitely needs to
be optimized quite substantially I think
our version is even easier to play as
well but you know it's not like it's not
training at
all so you can kind of just run some
experiments like this make sure you know
you're get it's getting some points run
some basic
sweeps there's also this default config
that has a bunch of sweep settings that
I think we're probably going to want to
change I think that most likely if
you're getting weird parameters out of
sweeps we're going to want to remove
like the uh the clipping coefficient and
the value clipping coefficient from here
probably we don't want to sweep
these uh I'll just tell you them hold
on batch size mini batch size we might
tweak here I'll just go through and tell
you really quick and you can just like
watch this VOD again if you want to it
use this as a reference
so ignore seed ignore deterministic CP
ignore all this total time steps how
long you train learning rate how big the
optimizer makes of steps an Neil we
actually turn this off by default this
is whether you decrease learning rate
over the course of a run uh it's fine
but it makes it harder to like train for
longer and get better results gam is the
discount Factor uh the rough way to
interpret this is It's The Horizon of
your task
so uh n the way you think about 0 N9 is
you care about things that are 100 steps
in the future which is quite long Lambda
is related you have to read the J paper
for this usually it gets set a little
bit lower like
99.95 or for short tasks like 0. n590
are pretty common
update epox is the number of times that
you train where you take an update on
stale data so how many times you use
each sample ignore this yes we normalize
advantages clip coefficient this is how
big your gradients are going to be how
big your steps have to take you away
from the old policy before you clamp
down on
gradients
um we're not even clamped down on
gradients hold on how the [ __ ] do we
actually use this this is implement a
Co yeah so this is It's a clamping
factor for uh the policy it tells you
how big of an update you're allowed to
make to the policy with any given batch
of data uh or with any yeah with any
given batch of data uh probably 0.1 or 2
these things don't want to be tuned
because uh carbs will what it'll do is
it'll set this really low which means
that you make uh you can only make very
small updates to the policy and then
it'll like say to use the same data 100
times or whatever it comes up with this
weird hack in order to like make
learning very fast but it's very
unstable to do that so we're probably
just going to take this out of the
default hyper pram sweeps value function
coefficient is how quickly you train the
portion of the model that tries to
predict what reward it's going to get
versus the rest of the model you can
leave this on tune it should probably be
somewhere between 0 five and two um but
you can probably just let this tune
itself value function clip coefficient
similar to clip coefficient probably
don't tune this so you can just delete
the tune section for this out of the
default config Max gradient Norm how big
the gradients are allowed to be before
you click clip them uh in order to
prevent the policy from blowing up
entropy is important entropy is the
stochasticity of the policy it's a term
that rewards stochasticity of policy so
uh the model is producing a distribution
over actions and this rewards the policy
for producing a non-deterministic
distribution so instead of just having
all the probability Mass on one action
it rewards it for you know uh trying out
different actions more often if you
crank this up then you'll just get a
random policy uh if you just put this to
zero sometimes it won't explore at all
early in training this one's pretty
sensitive usually somewhere between
0.001 and 0.02 is
good numm and num workers yeah bat size
is technically a hyper parameter but I
also kind of set this a
hardware uh same thing for BPT Horizon
you can let this just auto tune it
doesn't really matter the really big one
is when you have the total number of
environments if I set 4096 environments
is the total then the number that you
want to
compute let's say we have batch size
what is
it okay like this is our batch size and
then we're going to do
divide by number of
environments is
64 so you only actually get 64 steps out
of each
environment um in a batch of
260k which means you probably want to
have if you're going to use 4096
environments you probably want a batch
size of at least
260k which is huge but hey I mean that's
what you got to do if you want to get
the parallelism
from the 4096 M so I would generally
suggest uh keeping like at least a 64
ratio between batch size and number of
number of M's like that
um same thing sort of for mini batch
size like you probably don't want to
have more than like four or eight mini
batches per
batch so if you're going to have 2 to
the
18 uh batch size you probably want 2 to
the 16 mini batch or
something and that's mostly how I think
about hyper parameters it doesn't have
to be this genius thing that like you
know it's just some basic intuitions on
stuff you pretty much know enough to do
whatever from
there so you can refer to that
section if you just grab time stamp on
this what is this now we're 13 in so
however long I just rambled for
that's probably best until I can give
you on the whole RL side
actually there's some things in there
that took a while to
C assuming pong and breakout are in
decent shape and wise can I not
set band of values and let it sweep yeah
yeah you absolutely can do
that it tends to be a pretty iterative
process but yeah you can absolutely do
that I mean the process is like run
sweep see what happens like grab hyper
prams look at hyper prams do hyper prams
look somewhat sane if not try to figure
out why if so cool can you reproduce
them like does stuff run reasonably okay
great like save
checkpoint um save you know parameters
to config file so you have nice Baseline
that can run export weights now we have
weights that we can deploy to the
website like you know gets all the nice
Baseline stuff done
I'm going start using ins for actions I
think really doesn't save anything use
uh
chars do you like a certain fixed number
of
steps per combination of
sweep what you do you
can probably the best thing is to set a
band you just include total time steps
as sweep parameter right you set it like
between 50 million and like 500 million
or whatever uh and then you set the the
search center there's like a thing you
can just edit in demo. py it's hardcoded
for now you can just set it to like 100
million by default or whatever and then
it'll do like 100 million step runs
which should literally take 2 minutes um
with puffer each so very fast and then
if it needs more steps it'll go longer
and if it doesn't need as many steps
it'll go shorter cuz that's how carbs
works I'm going to push these nice
little fixes up as well but uh I mean
you can start on it whenever pretty much
whenever your box is up a welcome
YouTube folks
looks like stream's warmed up a
bit puffer fast enough I guess peffer is
fast enough where it's not really a
threat at least for those ends
yeah that's the point like puffer so
ridiculously fast you don't really have
to think very hard you can kind of just
run all the experiments and uh you'll
find out by running everything
you know let's save thinking for when we
actually need to
think we're g to give go the uh probably
shouldn't mess with go because you got a
PR for
I kind of like the idea of today being
big refactor day
this is going to really be a nice
Improvement to the uh the project I'd
say and I'm kind of tired but I think I
can get like all this
stuff nicely done today
yet it's an unsigned
sh he
yeah so this is not even added here this
is
fine TCG doesn't have a bind triple
Triad we can fix
uh you know yours is onedimensional
[Music]
right
yeah action
space
discret just what we like nice and
simple
what's this thing's obsession with
getting the dimensions
did somebody take I forget if somebody
took the pong refactor or the snake
refactor somebody take the pong refactor
or the snake refactor already
refactor oh uh yeah so this guy is going
to try to run a sweep on
pong try breakout I think breakout is
going to be a little harder to get to
work anyways than pong you can do uh you
can do pong if this guy can't if this
guy doesn't get it to work
I mean also you got triple Triad and
other stuff
right lots of
M lots of
Ms welcome YouTube folks
all right so this is actually in a good
spot just from
that what haven't we added
catch
here here to report that with no scon
optimization and tuning batch size and
numb workers we're at 10x speed up Godly
work thank
you so for small
networks in the realm of like 150k
parameter CNN plus
lstm uh a million steps per second
training is very possible with like
depends on your observations size and
with a slightly larger Network um like
300ish K you can still get like 300,000
plus steps per second
train any idea why
shaders are so slow in
what
uh I don't know what I don't know what
you're quite on about there
I think you're in the wrong stream for
that this is uh reinforcement learning
Dev
that's kind of at like asking like a car
mechanic like hey my car won't start
what's wrong with it you
know what are shaders that I can tell
you shaders
are uh Hardware optimized little
programs
that take the 3D data uh from your scene
typically like the vertices of meshes as
well as the actual the points on your
screen and figures out what to render at
every point they're used for lighting
they're used for special effects they're
used for
postprocessing used for tons of
have you tried uh have you tried fueling
it with sugar sugar is like really good
for getting me to wake up so maybe if
you give the car some sugar the car will
wake
up there are always
bugs but we are good at crushing bugs
going doing
some refactor
on the scyon bindings for stuff today in
order to
eliminate some common user
bugs I don't know why I messed this up
this is unsigned
Char is a m
still but
overall and we get to remove this
stuff we might have to uh remove some of
the warnings here
we'll
see so I
did which of the core M have I not done
yet on
this I did this one this one doesn't
have binding this one doesn't have
binding I did the snake G I did this I
did this did this okay I think that's
all of them we just have to actually
test and make sure all this stuff works
now and uh we should be
good I'm tempted to get some coffee or
something man I'm just been like so
tired this
week it's like I'll be doing well and
then I'll go like do some hard run or
some like heavy lifts or something and I
like exhaust myself for several
days okay uh let me at least go put the
kettle on I'll be back in a second what
[Music]
right so I guess we'll just try to
fix existing
stuff for
subscript I don't understand this
warning
on I'm confused as to whether I did this
correctly or
not this is kind of gross cast intax
I mean does this actually ever get
filled anywhere hold on I think I can
just
simplify this doesn't actually get used
directly as cool as this syntax is I
think that this is uh this might have
been a mistake
it appears to the compiler that you're
treating observations as a on
demray you attempt to cast it to a two
[Music]
demoray this creates a pointer
each row is 510 bytes
well no I cast
here and then we have 5 10 bytes as
expected
right so and observations of PID
this gives me
500 10
bytes hid element into an
array this is problematic does not
match cannot
guarantee that the pointer arithmetic is
safe
this is triggering the boundex
error is calculating the index and this
interprets as an axis within the single
dimension of size 510
H going back to hypers for a
second would you generally set clip Voss
to
True
yes I wouldn't touch I wouldn't touch
the default Boolean
parameters those should be
okay yeah so it understands this this is
correct
so this is the important bit with memory
layout
see so according to this I should be
able to add an 11 here
expression unsign
Char star OBS
better maybe it is Maybe it is better to
just do stuff flat and not have this
stupid cast
I think this works I hope I don't break
it in the process I really do
compiles now we've got the
snake the snake stuff
I mean I guess I could do that refactor
right
[Music]
now I guess I could do that refactor
right
yeah this is special net we don't need
this
one uh isn't there anything that I use
the
CNN lstm model
on guess not
okay that's
fine then we do step and then we do
render and you got to do
like this
well don't need any of this anymore this
has all been
ported into
actions ought to
be regular int not unsigned
Triad no warnings compiling all ends is
going to be
beautiful unsign Char star actions yes
so there's no reason for
okay that's a whole bunch of M's
compiled a whole bunch of compiled
M's there's going to be some work to
make sure that they all uh they're all
valid but we now have a bunch of nicely
compiled ends
pong pong does work it just takes a
while to get logs
annoying because we don't do frame skip
I
runs we can always consider log
frequency after
Connect 4 is the one that's in progress
fine I have to mess with that a little
today
oh there's like this OB size that's no
big
[Music]
vations output
dumped yeah we don't have a policy for
it right
this
okay we hear the
snakes I can control this one the rest
of them are waiting for their new policy
to be added is just fine by me
don't see anything that should break it
here
you get a nice discr action space Oh I
didn't even Port this [ __ ] did
I I didn't even Port
this yeah this whole L needs a big clean
up there's way too much logic in here
it's just so funny how like it gets the
library just gets getting it like gets
progressively better so darn
quickly
like yeah this was the level that it was
at like just three months ago it's
gotten so much
better yep
probably we just haven't even like I
mean this needs a port right
I'm
dumb this one is
fine yeah this is fine because we're not
actually using this one
right okay so all we have to do is clean
up yeah yeah yeah okay here's the new
version we're good with this
I mean to be fair there are a number of
things that this could be that are like
completely
reasonable you can't even compile with
stupid address sanitizer though can
you
ah this goes at the bottom doesn't
that's
it
silly unaligned Tash
chunk the
hell what is this
trying to
bizarre sad thing is this is not even a
c problem it's freaking scon being
obnoxious
I don't think this should freaking
matter
Bizarro if this fixes it I'll be shocked
but
did it just make
this oh no it's okay
no way that fixes
it
really wait I'm so
confused oh did I just forget to run
setup before
know couple more things like this I'll
have to check in core before
1.1 that's like Giga cursed
it works though
right just run this a little bit to make
sure yeah just
learning that's nice
that's how it should
be return is crazy low
too that fixes the main stuff
though I guess I got to check the Moa
indexing that's
lame how do I mess that up
huh yeah I must have been doing this on
the bigger boxes right
there you
go trains
immediately okay I think that's all of
the current
environments updated for this new system
format
um yeah that's all the big
ones there a few that are missing
bindings and stuff that'll have to be in
this format when they get
added Pretty good overall uh I think I
should probably test
these
multiprocessing right
that alignment bug is like really
freaking weird I'm trying to think how
that could even
missing from SE snake
oh this is just missing a
buff no big deal see if we get the
alignment bug
still kind of
impressive that this is actually a
problem
I wonder if the alignment is different
for Char and sign char
I'm having the hard time believing this
is
that's so
bizarre that there'd actually be an
alignment bug on
what the hell should even require
alignment for
let me go back because I really don't
want to have to deal with shared memory
if there's like um I mean alignment if
there's a better
require without this it breaks
right even with Native
space no it's 11 by 11
right which is
121 it's not a multiple of four
is that actually
it that's absolutely disgusting if
that you can't just pad like
that you have to uh
reshape e
you can't even do this because this will
mess up the addressing
jeez and I honestly don't even know why
the
numpy why numpy aligning fixes
it there's a different shape that we can
use
mean there's not like a good thing that
fixes this I don't I don't know why I
haven't run into this before either
actually that's a good question why
haven't I run into this before if this
is if this is a
um seems like it works
now is Bizarro
well if I run into this I know that
there's some
bug wa what if I do V
multiprocessing get it
is there's are
unaligned access right
there that's non
deterministic
non deterministic alignment crashing
bug that's a new one
this one is tough because this is like
such a
fundamental well hang on a
second this really doesn't make sense
that you're not allowed to pass this
around does
you know I wonder if this is the memory
slice memory view
thing I should be able to see this
though in
Native he only shows up sometimes and
sometimes in multi it like sometimes in
weird well not what I wanted to be
dealing with today but
um I'm just going to assume that this
bug shouldn't
exist and I will eventually figure out
why this happens because I should be
able to pass charge russes
[Music]
around really
should oh it's seg fults part though
that's even weirder
possibly just have to run this for
longer and
that training policies
just ignore this for
now
230 um I just cleaned up all of the M's
really the ones on the main page at
least haven't done go
yet I'm going to merge the uh the go
PR in a bit for Spencer
I think this is solid
um I'm going to want to merge all this
stuff and probably fix con four at the
same
there all right I'm going to go get
myself cup of coffee or something um
and
then I think we'll try to fix Connect 4
today that'll have it in a pretty good
spot I'd say
overall some stuff to do on the Moa as
well there a few other things but I
think that'll get us into a decent spot
for the release I think that's like the
biggest the biggest source of error um
solved except for the potential issue of
this ridiculous alignment
thing which really shouldn't exist so
we'll see was I'll be right
mic I mean I really didn't mess too much
up with the connect 4M right I was
probably just tired last
night oh yeah we also have the cool uh
en we've got the uh the awesome website
thing to look at as
well that'll be nice
okay I think it was just straight up
taking invalid moves right
Jason I'm not really sure what your
comment
move yeah okay so there's a bug with
this end
wait what
something screw with this
I think you should probably tweak
this yeah I think he should probably
tweak this because I think that this
isn't I don't think I introduced
here all these M's are good do I have a
PR on the
website I have a PR on the
website broke 700 members on the Discord
that's pretty
so let's see we get the index
file is now it
has some CSS stuff on it
placeholder I see so I have to fill this
in of
course we can do that now
then thing is the boxes aren't fully
lined up
right stuff's not fully lined
up
okay this is almost almost perfect a few
small things that we got to do with it
oh you can literally scroll in the
background that's kind of cool
panel I think
I think you just forgot this
right you just do this and put this
where was this
go you have to relaunch this
thing oh wait wait no
I yeah just it's in lined like
first okay now it's less rounded it's
got a little bit of
round and this tactical thing
thing I think there is is a loading
thing
right
unfortunately we're going to end up
having such fast load times we're not
going to need a loading screen but I've
had a really fun idea for one
I want to get
like inflating puffer with bicycle pump
is the loading
screen I think that'd be
uh let's change
this on
wait what did this just change
completely
this just put itself on
top
oh
what that's kind of
and you literally just have to click
outside of it as
well or hit
Escape that's pretty
snazy
okay so yeah there's just some very
small like format things being screwy it
looked
I guess I should just add the rest of
the content in here for
now and hopefully
hey I love being able to just do this
stuff and get people to just jump on to
stream this makes stuff so much
welcome thank you for the website
redesign yeah I see
you sometimes it'll eat messages on X
but I do see
you so
this is
awesome
um there
are like a few small layout bugs I think
but I really like the way that you've
gone with this
um
so a few things here um the first
thing yeah no this is great uh the first
thing and this might not even be an HTML
thing this might be like a weird M
script and thing um I think right now we
like we compile everything so that it
gets like packed into individual builds
so we like we end up repacking a bunch
of resources a whole bunch of times like
we end up repackaging the whole
resources folder I'm pretty sure every
time um I don't know if there's some way
to prune or like you know share them
across M's or
something but
I think that like the resources should
be small enough that we should be able
to basically like install
load we should be able to like install
load
everything um so that's that's probably
the most complicated thing I'm going to
ask you for uh the rest of it is a lot
simpler it's just stuff
like this panel here I couldn't figure
out do you know how like to fix here
it's kind of hard to see but if
[Music]
you
here it let me do
this like
it's it's like doing like this weird
rounding and shading thing here and it's
also like it's the wrong
size
um I mean the biggest thing is it's
being the wrong size and I can't figure
out how to like get this box to be
like flush with it I made a couple small
edits to like the rounding prams and
stuff
um I think it would be also be really
good if we could figure out I don't know
if there's an easy way to get the size
uh of the
environment from the web assembly or
from what like from whatever this is
contained in so we make this window be
the right size cuz like if you zoom in
it kind of works
right like it kind of works in that it
like it puts it in this container but
not
really um I noticed that you actually
you have it really good when you do like
this this is really good cuz this will
be yeah you made like this phone layout
or
whatever um this is really
solid again it's like the I don't know
if the zoom works the way it should
right like it if you zoom it like screws
up the
view so basically there's just like a
bunch of little scaling stuff I think is
the main thing the only thing I wasn't
the only other thing I wasn't sure about
um
was I don't know if so now that you just
have like this click and it's on the
same screen if it makes more sense to
just have this fill horizontal just like
however much space you have on screen it
like just shows as much stuff as you can
so like since I have this super wide
it'll probably just like it could put
them all across this way maybe two
rows but yeah there's just basically
like some scaling stuff um if you know
how to do that uh that type of stuff
would be
awesome I didn't want to like go mess up
all your nice
uh your nice CSS and stuff um so I
didn't like go try to hack anything all
I did was mess with a couple small
parameters
um
yeah I really like the way that this
works now though this is pretty cool
that it's just clean like
this not super
experienced with it but can try well
which which part is hard like which is
the thing that's hard
there if you can't figure out how to do
resource load stuff that's
fine resource load thing can be last cuz
that's like that's going from high perf
to even like we already have very good
load times so it's getting it just like
even crazier good load times I think the
initial thing would just be to like fix
a bunch of the scaling
Jank
um cuz basically like I did in the
initial page I just figured okay I don't
know what I'm doing so I'm going to just
like make something super basic so like
nothing goes weird right cuz it's just
going to be like on a new
page but yeah here it's like there's
scaling stuff to look
at front end generally but can mess with
it hey you got more than I
place I like like what you did though
you know you didn't mess with the whole
build process it's just an HTML file and
you like this is plenty we don't really
need any heavy framework [ __ ] like
this is like this type of stuff is
plenty we really don't need anything
like more sophisticated than this this
is like exactly the type of thing that I
wanted uh really cool to see that you
can just do this I didn't actually know
that it was easy to just do this in like
standard CSS JavaScript whatever
um I don't know I don't know any front
end though yeah no react is very nice
react is like no pain
please but yeah just like if you can
like play around with a bit of the
scaling stuff that would be awesome we
got all these M's um I just fixed up uh
one last thing with the compilation
today so we should be pretty soon we
should be able to put like deployed
policies on all of them like this is is
a deployed policy and you can like yeah
this is a deployed policy we'll have
deployed policies for all of them pretty
soon so will be really cool to be able
to like have this thing with that I
don't know if you can get the the size
of this
Frame it's like all this black space
yeah I don't know if there's like a way
to just like this size right next to
here or whatever
but yeah definitely thanks for the help
with this this is
cool I have an ocean of
environments try to size it yeah if you
can just size it relative to the game if
you can like just generally figure out
how to like make this thing scale better
if it can be flushed to the window or
like if you can figure out how to make
the game not cut off off like this you
see like you try to expand and like the
expand option will like cut the game off
um instead of like making the whole
thing bigger it's kind of
weird like you can't even scroll in here
or anything so it's
like yeah
I think that what you would want is
you'd probably
want either well it keeps the window
pretty constant size so I guess it would
just expand this
side yeah no this is way better than
what I had
do that I'll be happy to like merge all
this and and then we'll have a nice
updated website with this thank you very
much and haven't
seen haven't seen David's breakout fixes
yet
uh I think
generally all these M are in a decent
spot
we've basically we've got two projects
that haven't been started
properly and then a few that need like
some substantial work to
finish but a lot of them are in a pretty
good spot
already I got to add Spencer's
go PR onto this
deep in thought welcome bet I just was
checking out arb's
um website
redesign pretty
cool yeah I gave him a few I think he
might still be here um I gave him a few
small things just with like the scaling
so things don't get cut off and stuff
few small things to fix but I really
like how this is like I mean this is
plenty right this level of like engage
like this level of design is plenty
doesn't need react doesn't need any
annoying Frameworks that are going to be
a pain to maintain it's still nice and
fast the only portion that's slower like
the games that load a bunch of stuff I
think there's some ways to optimize
those as well but you know they're
pretty
fast so I think that this is great
I think this is going to be really
good thanks for the advertising bet yes
please do star the puffer helps out a
ton
missing nope
nothing where is the
link there should be a link to it there
is a link to it there's the Discord
button
right I mean there's a button there's
like all this stuff oh to puffer GG yeah
yeah yeah that's going to be on the main
page I need to do a lot of work on the
main page not even like design work just
like I need to do like information work
like that page needs to be substantially
updated the link to start puffer lib is
right there
well I get how buttons are tiny I don't
know well this is 100% now
nice demo
page we'll be able to replace the
uh does this still work yeah we'll be
able to like replace these things with
the the single web page which will be
nice
try think what else I should do today to
uh cuz we've got all the M's in a decent
spot except like
I'm trying to now think about the
biggest things remaining for 1.1
right there are a couple big M's that
still need me to do a substantial amount
of
work there's some smaller Ms that need
Bas lines and fixes which I think for
the most part between you and Spencer
and you know all the other new
contributors I think that should be
mostly
good figure out how to make a twisting
road if you got a code for me to look at
I'll look at
don't this is my cross to bear
okay well I'll link you to a place where
you can probably find some similar
code
um like
thing Dam it
this environment you can
probably you know you can probably get
something out of this logic
wise cuz I think that this thing is like
some garbage python code
so yeah here's they have 700 some odd
lines for this which is way more than
they need I'm
sure
cool looks like you're getting closer
yeah you can look at some of this this
is not good code but it probably has
some of the stuff you're looking
just yeah it's going to be like a little
basic trig or something
um I think everything else is pretty
well set I think it's really now just
about
getting the more complex M's
running and training something
reasonable I could start trying to do
ELO
overtime like long train runs on the
mooba that could be interesting
actually let me go look at that mobo
run what's stopping us from doing robot
Sim well just the there's nothing
stopping us and I'd like to have
contributors doing stuff on this it's
just like not having time to do yet more
projects nothing stopping us we can
totally do it it's just a matter of time
investment and the like
there are a lot of things we can do
MOA maybe there's a better physics back
end yeah I think we might end up writing
one I'm not going to lie
we might end up writing
one oh yeah let's train the let's
retrain the
really I mean it depends how what the
Fidelity and such that you need is right
right I don't think it would be too
oh
[ __ ] oh no no we're good we're good this
was me yeah we're
I made a a pretty darn big Improvement
to
the scyon rappers
okay so that's
500k train
nothing really to
tweet just watch run
holy good train
curves these are good train curves and
it runs nice and
fast I mean
really practically I think all I have to
do is get a decent carb sweep setup for
this
thing run like a decent carb sweep over
a restricted number of parameters
for like say 500 mil or whatever
steps and
then run that policy for way longer with
carbs to tell me ELO over
time and I think I can actually
finish at least the 10 version of this
project I mean these M are not required
to
be a static right
them that actually looks nice and stable
I need to like accumulate them or
something but let's see how long this
stays the
case can see some of them are starting
to
level
to level here would be interesting to
here would be interesting to
see why that
I kind of want to change some of the
sweep defaults
frankly I think that's a good
idea cuz we're sweeping too much stuff
and it's causing
we'll see if it does weird things with
this
ratio what if we do like this
mini batch goes
from there's still a crazy potential
ratio but we'll see with
this I'd hope this will be more stable
at the very
Bill and this is kind of insane right
this is kind of
deranged we can do two bill is
fine batch
size
I still think that there's going to be
potential for this to
abuse uh to abuse its
settings I mean the only solution to
this is unfortunately to just like cut
out these parameters
like you don't always want to sweep your
batch size right like what if we just
say screw it we're not doing
this we just be like we're going to
sweep their default stuff as well as
time steps and some rewards and
whatever kind of just fine
right huh I even think that's I think
that's way
better I think that is way
better well we we can try it and see but
it takes a little
while that's a big step per second drop
that's weird
0% and if it doesn't take 0% like we can
make it take 0%
processes but there was a big dip as
well I don't know what
happened yeah so somehow there was like
this big jump right here
see this policy
losses no I'm not doing anything that
weird now these I think could be from
games being synced up
I guess the episode returns are pretty
indicative right these are still
trending up some of the I think some of
like the individual
characters I just I can't figure out
what to
do there's some funny reward curves that
Well Carrie figured it
out one of them
did no it's the other way around
actually is that it doesn't
pre-compute it doesn't pre-compute any
pathing and uh it just caches it caches
paths now but the thing is it's shared
like that array should be
shared
um but that array should be shared so it
really shouldn't be able to take up any
time I mean I could double check if I'm
being really stupid here but I doubt it
I'll show you what I'm
doing I don't think that's going to help
but here
fair I actually no this is an
address you see it's passing the address
here you
see so that buffer is getting shared
across all the M's so it's really it's 3
seconds at most to the total compute
time for
pathing we know it's just the
environment started taking longer so I
mean that could be many things
though it's weird that it happened all
of a
sudden maybe some of them froze or
something I don't know
solid whether this is truly stable we'll
see some of these are still reasonable
though these are all are just really
cool really cool training
curves feels like we've uh We've hit the
point of the project where stuff starts
to make sense a
bit I'll
leave I will leave
Val finishing MOA is going to be good I
mean I I me this uh this spot where I've
got like too many big things that need
to be finished
um I think just finishing one of them
will be very
helpful I do wish we had better like if
we had like the graphics and animations
and stuff for this it would be nice
but I mean I'll just finish like I'll
fix like a couple the bugs like this
like off by one bug or whatever with the
terrain
and I'll like load in like the
animations for like the icons and
here more useful with assisting oh I
mean it takes a while right
the mechanics aren't sophisticated
enough that it makes sense to like move
like you would in League or
DOTA right you've got this Dash strike
but there's
not I mean some of the Dynamics work
just some of the like the Autos don't
really do much cuz there's no like
there's no spacing or anything like that
this is definitely going to be a very
good M though if it's if I can fully
finish
it like we have several now I think that
are going to be on the more complex side
we need to get devs on um TCG and we
need to get devs on Robo code those two
will also be nice and I think those two
will be slightly easier in some
sense I think those two will be slightly
going to go run then yard
work see you around yep thank you doar
puffer the fact that this thing
continues to train over this amount of
time is encouraging I will
say like that there seems to be
stuff
happening the fact that like some of um
it doesn't seem to be symmetric
though like this this character
learns like this type of thing is
not encouraging
thing I wonder how hard it would be to
actually like
script a decent opponent team
that'd be probably pretty substantial of
an undertaking
right I mean I could just
give I could just give them like the
minion AI right
that would make it a lot
easier because then I would have a
version where it's not just pure
selfplay
I think that would probably be good that
would be good to
do yeah that's a good
idea time is it four
um to end early today go do some stuff
let this run and then maybe come back in
the
evening and work on this MOBA a
bit I think that's probably going to be
the best thing to do
I figured out a few good things here
today though and we got that uh that
good commit
in so pensive day but
um good progress on a few important
things the alignment bug is a little
Jank we'll figure that out
though all right I'll probably be back
streaming again later in the evening uh
I do want to get more stuff done on M
today I'm going to let this run for a
bit though so